hi I'm not Olivia Laveau's here at big
Android BBQ in hurst texas with stacy
devon oh she's an Android developer and
i just wanted to ask her a couple
questions before we all depart the great
state of texas hey Stacy how are you
doing doing just fine ready for some
meat so I see these pins on you can you
tell me a little bit about the culture
of these pins and how many years you've
been coming to big Android BBQ these are
just the pins I have accumulated pretty
much from this barbecue and Google i/o
there was a big Android event also held
like as an after party so yeah I've been
coming gosh this is probably my fourth
year okay I think yeah I might be fit
it's a part of the Android culture to
get pins from different companies that
are represented at Android event oh no
this is this is a big Android thing this
is not it but no it's it's it's all
about representation and so fabulous
that these guys actually support us yeah
yeah it's really cool you have like
Facebook you have Golden Gate Bridge we
have some startups to that we're also
present so it's really it's really cool
to see ya um so I wanted to to get
started how did you get into mobile
development like why Android so I
started really young with a poem so I
first learned on palm see in middle
school because my dad worked for 3.com
at the time and then that just kept fun
progressing and did stuff with iPods and
then initially some iphone stuff but
don't talk so much about that but then
android came on the scene and they
didn't call it hacking they called it
development and that's what really
attracted me to android and what was
your first project that you were proud
of or maybe you even had challenges on
but that at the end of the day once you
solve for it was that's your first love
so i did some work for the military and
emergency services and put out a product
by myself in a very very short time
frame that was kind of revolutionising
for the industry and i just i literally
worked 120 hours one week and 90 hours
was my average so it was it was one of
those things that I just was I couldn't
believe I was capable of it and you can
be amazed what you can push yourself
through yeah
so when you're in those stressful
moments what makes you calm or what or
what is the tool that you use to
persevere is it long walks on the beach
is it really it's a belief that the
world was basically revolutionized by
people no smarter no more capable than
you are so what's stopping you from
achieving what they did and the it's
just an inner fire keep trying until you
fail and then fail again and then as
long as time still available fail as
many times as you can until you get it
right so one of the things that I love
about you is that you're a maker in a
lot of different capacities right so
you're an Android maker if you if you
were to see it that way but you also
have been getting into a lot of 3d
printing and you're a member of the
Dallas makerspace can you tell me a
little bit why about why making it so
important so making is the ability to
take your ideas and make them tangible
and the ability to communicate and learn
from people beyond just work beyond just
what people might think that you should
know I mean some of my best friends are
both software developers and blacksmiths
things that you wouldn't actually
consider but it really gives you that
that this is only so satisfying
sometimes sometimes you just need to
craft something do something creative
and you know ultimately at the end of
the day you can't rely on your employer
took one hundred percent provide
everything for you in terms of
creativity you have to go and make
yourself a multi-faceted person and that
actually ends up opening a lot of
opportunities at work yeah so one of the
things I just wanted to share with our
developers at home so stacy is also
women techmakers lead and so she created
us these really cool custom women
techmakers Android figurines and I'm
going to be taking back to my desk in
mountain view so speaking of that your
women techmakers lead can you tell me
what you think the the industry needs to
do to support more women to come into
Android development or to be designer or
maybe a founder of her own startup so
this is something I've actually talked
about with leaders of pretty well-known
companies
it's not that we need to encourage more
it's just that we need to discourage
less we just need to tell somebody hey
you know it's okay something didn't go
right there's a lot of feelings as a
woman that you have to be everything to
everyone and when you say it's okay if
something had a bug other person had a
bug you know two weeks ago it's okay
you're going to do well so by actually
not even just encouraging but just don't
don't discourage them you know yeah and
also don't give up right i think that
failure is ok but and i also think that
when you're failing having a supportive
team as as oh yeah i failed to write
it's almost like creating a supportive
network of failure no one actually
leaves a certain failure circle of
failure yeah exactly so you know i think
that you're right when we when we create
that kind of ecosystem and community
like big Android BBQ right all these
people are here and our supportive
Network for when you're developing
something right Oh totally I mean I
can't tell you how many times like I've
seen Virginia's artwork paired with like
another one of my friends friends
development skills and they just come
out with this totally cool thing that
they just did after work one weekend I
mean and we see the same people at the
same event but that's because they're
our friends there are network and when I
have trouble with something I know
exactly who to go to for that problem
and it ultimately makes you a better
developer and a better person too
awesome well I know we all got to get
down to the BBQ that's what we came here
for besides an atonement so as I say
thank you so much for coming out talking
to us and thanks so much for being a
great women techmakers as well thank you
very much Natalie so not Olivia love us
again bringing some live insights and
tips from stacy at big Android BBQ I
think this concludes our interviews for
big Android BBQ and just tuned in more
for women techmakers sessions coming up
you